hey 42 here more than 50% of people in
the world have never made or received a
telephone call welcome to RIF only 2% of
the world population are natural
redheads but Scotland has the highest
density of redheads in Scotland 13% of
the population are ginger the second
month to go over Niagara Falls in a
barrel
Bobby leach survived the fall but he
later died as a result of slipping on a
piece of orange peel Thomas Edison's
last breath is held in a vial at the
Henry Ford Museum in Detroit in ancient
Greek the word idiot meant anyone who
wasn't a politician until 1913 children
in America could legally be sent by
Parcel Post under extremely high
pressures diamonds can actually be made
from peanut butter the water in the
mouths of a blue whale weighs more than
its body
Colgate faced a big obstacle when
marketing toothpaste in spanish-speaking
countries because Colgate translates
into the command go hang yourself gold
is extremely rare on earth all the gold
ever mined would fit into two Olympic
sized swimming pools and finally the
phrase rule of form is derived from an
old English law which stated that you
couldn't beat your wife with anything
wider than your foot thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42